Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à tous.
Je m’appelle Aton, je suis acteur,
auteur et aussi ancien GIGN.
On va remonter -
J’ai plein de choses à vous dire,
mais tout ça, ça prend naissance,
en fait, quand j’étais petit.
Quand j’étais enfant, j’ai été victime
de ce qu’on appelle le harcèlement.
J'étais un peu chahuté par des camarades,
et pas seulement forcément des camarades,
mais des enfants adolescents, qui étaient
un petit peu plus âgés que moi,
et qui me tournaient en dérision
et qui me harcelaient.
Je trouvais ça extrêmement injuste
et j’avais envie d’apporter
une réponse à ça.
Mais quand on est enfant, on n’a pas
forcément toutes les armes
et c’est très difficile d’en parler.
Alors, je me suis tourné vers la fiction,
vers le cinéma.
Mes inspirations étaient
les acteurs hollywoodiens.
Je suis né fin 70, en 78.
Mes inspirations étaient Sylvester
Stallone, Arnold Schwarzenegger,
Jean-Claude Vandamme,
des gens comme ça,
des gens qui étaient forts.
Sylvester Stallone, c'était Rocky,
c'était Rambo.
Schwarzenegger, c’était son film Predator.
Il avait des bras comme ça,
indestructible.
Dans ces gens-là,
j’ai eu cette inspiration
qui m’a donné de la force.
J’avais envie d’être eux
parce qu’ils étaient respectés.
Et je me suis dit :
« Si j’arrivais à être aussi fort qu’eux,
je serais fort pour me défendre, moi,
mais je pourrais même défendre au-delà,
je pourrais défendre ceux que j’aime. »
Et ça, c'était très important pour moi.
J'étais très tourné vers la famille,
vers les proches.
Donc ma vocation,
pour moi, c’était clair :
je serai acteur hollywoodien plus tard.
Hyper ambitieux.
Tout le monde me disait
que c’était un doux rêve
et qu’être acteur à Hollywood,
c’était réservé à très peu de gens
sur cette Terre
et que c’étaient des gens
qui étaient exceptionnels.
Est-ce qu’ils étaient seulement humains ?
La question se posait.
La question, je me la posais, en tout cas.
Les années sont passées.
À l’âge de 16 ans, en 1994,
je suis témoin d’une intervention du GIGN.
C’est celle de Marseille Marignane.
Ce sont les images qu’on a tous en tête de
cette passerelle qui arrive sur cet avion,
avec ces gens qui sont cagoulés,
gilets pare-balles, armes à la main,
et qui pénètrent dans l’avion et qui
vont libérer les plus de 270 otages.
Et là, pour moi,
il se passe quelque chose.
Je me dis : « Mais qui sont ces hommes ? »
Moi, je rêve d’être un acteur.
Mais les acteurs jouent.
Eux, ils ont joué leur vie.
C'est du vrai.
Ma vocation n’a pas changé,
parce que j’ai toujours
cette ambition de devenir acteur,
mais je me suis dit :
« Pourquoi pas être GIGN avant ?
Et faire peut-être pour de vrai ce que
je pourrais faire après pour de faux ? »
Donc je me suis intéressé au GIGN.
Peut-être que ce sera plus
accessible dans un premier temps.
Je me suis concentré sur qui ils étaient.
Dans les reportages que je pouvais voir,
les livres que je pouvais lire,
c’étaient des dieux, c’étaient
des gens qui n’étaient pas humains.
C'était surhumain.
Mais il en fallait plus
pour me décourager.
Je me suis dit :
« A moi de devenir aussi un héros.
En passant par le GIGN,
je serai un héros du GIGN.
Après, je serai un héros comme
Sylvester Stallone, Schwarzenegger,
ou Jean-Claude Vandamme
ou bien d’autres. »
Donc, j’ai commencé à m’entraîner.
Là encore, les gens qui m’entouraient
me disaient :
« Tu sais, le GIGN, regarde
les reportages, c’est super dur.
Regarde-toi enfin. Je veux dire, tu ne
fais pas deux mètres, tu ne fais pas...
- Pour l’instant, non. J’ai 16 ans.
Mais en même temps, je vais travailler.
Je vais travailler, je vais m’entraîner,
et je finirai peut-être par y arriver. »
Pour moi, c’est accessible :
je pouvais être un héros.
Pourquoi ? Parce que je n’avais pas
expérimenté la vie.
Je n'avais pas eu beaucoup
d'échecs dans ma vie.
Je réussissais ce que j’entreprenais.
Donc ça, c’était une étape en plus,
c’était un objectif en plus ;
j’étais convaincu que j’allais y arriver.
Mais plus je m'entraînais
et plus je souffrais.
Plus je souffrais,
plus je me posais des questions,
à savoir : est-ce que ce rêve,
cette ambition, est réalisable ?
Quand j’étais blessé,
je me disais :
« Les hommes du GIGN à ma place,
je suis sûr qu’ils seraient pas blessés.
Je suis sûr que,
quand l’entraînement est dur,
pour eux, ce n’est pas comme pour moi ;
pour eux, c’est facile. »
Et je me suis éloigné
de cette ambition, de ce rêve,
qui me semblait inaccessible.
Tous les gens autour de moi,
en majorité, me disaient :
« C’est bien, tu reviens à la raison. »
Et je me suis posé la question :
« Qu’est-ce que je vais faire
de ma vie ? »
Si ça, c’est inaccessible,
parce que je ne suis qu’un humain.
Moi, je ne suis qu'un être humain.
Je cours, je suis fatigué, je m’essouffle.
Je tombe, je me fais mal.
Je n’ai pas forcément envie de continuer
parce que j’ai mal.
J'ai envie de me soigner.
Je me suis posé la question : « Qu’est-ce
que je pouvais faire d’autre ? »
Et en fait, rien.
Je n’avais rien envie de faire d’autre
que d’être GIGN et d’être acteur.
Donc je me suis dit : « Écoute,
Qui sont ces hommes-là ?
Est-ce qu’ils sont humains ? »
Foncièrement, c’est vraiment
la question qu’il faut se poser
pour savoir si, moi aussi,
je peux devenir cet homme-là.
Donc j’ai fait le chemin inverse.
Je me dis : « Eux sont GIGN, ils ont
la cagoule, ils ont la combinaison.
Avant, qu’est-ce qu’ils étaient ? »
C’étaient des gendarmes, tel qu’il
pouvait y avoir sur le bord des routes.
Déjà, il y a un visage et plus
la cagoule, c’est beaucoup plus humain.
Et avant, qu’est-ce qu’ils étaient ?
Ils étaient lycéens, collégiens,
ils étaient comme moi, en fait.
Donc, ça m’a ouvert
un champ des possibles.
Comme ils sont partis comme moi :
collège, lycée, école de gendarmerie,
gendarme, GIGN.
En fait, c’est possible.
J’ai travaillé, je me suis entraîné.
Me dire que ces gens-là étaient humains,
étaient comme moi,
ça m’a motivé.
Je me suis entraîné, je n’ai rien lâché,
je me suis dit :
« La seule chose à ne pas oublier,
c’est le travail. »
Et j’ai travaillé, travaillé,
avec acharnement.
J’ai réussi ma semaine de test -
on est en 2003 -
j’ai réussi les tests
et j’arrive à l’entretien du GIGN
devant mes futurs camarades potentiels.
Et tellement je suis à l’aise,
je suis chez moi, ça y est, j’y crois,
je leur dis : « Vous savez qu’en fait,
entre vous et moi, il n’y a pas
de différence, je suis comme vous. »
C’était pour leur dire :
« Prenez-moi parce qu’on est pareils. »
Et là, ils ont éclaté de rire.
Je leur ai dit :
« Franchement, j’y crois.
La seule différence entre vous et moi,
c’est que vous êtes formés,
vous avez vécu quelques interventions
qui font que vous avez plus d’expérience.
Mais à la base, je suis le même guerrier
que vous ; je suis pareil. »
Ça les a fait rire.
Je suis rentré quand même au GIGN.
Je ne pense pas
qu’ils m’aient pris pour ça,
mais je pense que j’avais fait mes preuves
dans toutes les épreuves
que j’avais passées.
Je rentre au GIGN, je fais mes tests,
mon pré-stage, mon année de formation.
A la fin de la formation,
on est récompensé par la remise du brevet,
brevet qu’on vous remet sur la poitrine,
qui dit que vous êtes opérationnel.
C’est Thierry Prungnaud qui m’a remis
le brevet ; Il n’avait plus la cagoule.
C’est celui qui est rentré le premier
à Marignane avec le revolver.
C’était la première fois que je le voyais.
C’était ce héros, le héros,
le surhumain, le Dieu.
Il arrive vers moi, avec un bomber,
avec un bras abîmé parce
qu’il a encore ses blessures.
Il me remet le brevet et me dit :
« Porte-le haut et sois-en fier. »
Là, je me dis :
« En fait, Thierry, c’est un homme. »
On a discuté, on a échangé
et ma carrière a commencé.
Je me suis très vite rendu compte
qu’effectivement, être au GIGN,
c’est être au service,
mais c’est aussi être humain.
En fait, on fait avec ce qu’on a,
on fait comme on peut.
Cette image que
la population a du GIGN -
le soldat hyper fort -
ça nous galvanise,
ça nous donne du courage.
On se dit : « On appartient à ça. »
On est un groupe, c’est très fermé.
En même temps, on se relaye.
On n’est jamais en permanence GIGN.
Le GIGN, c’est quatre sections et on
est d’alerte deux semaines par mois.
Donc, en fait, c'est un relais.
Ce qui permet à l’humain, aux humains
que nous sommes,
de nous reposer, de nous entraîner,
de nous remettre en condition.
Ça, c’est ce qu’il y a derrière le rideau.
C’est ce que les gens ne voient pas.
Pendant ma carrière au GIGN, j’ai vu des
hommes blessés, j’ai vu des hommes mourir.
C’est le côté humain
que la population ne voit pas.
Elle ne voit que le super-héros,
le GIGN dans son ensemble.
Le GIGN, il y a des retraités que certains
croisent sans savoir qu’ils en sont.
Et il y a des gens qui y travaillent,
mais qui n’en sont pas moins humains.
J’ai eu la chance
de faire pas mal d’interventions,
notamment une à Dammartin
où j’étais prévu en tête
pour faire face aux frères Kouachi.
Cette force du groupe et de ce super-héros
que représente le GIGN,
dont j’étais une des composantes -
On est prêts au sacrifice ultime
parce qu’on est porté
par la vocation et par la population.
Je sentais vraiment la population
qu’il y avait derrière moi, derrière nous,
à dire : « Vas-y, on est avec toi. »
On était là pour protéger la population
et donner tout ce qu’on avait de meilleur
en nous pour faire barrage au terrorisme.
Voilà comment j’ai quitté le GIGN, c’était
une de mes dernières interventions.
J’ai quitté - on ne peut pas être plus
humain - avec une prothèse aux cervicales
et une partielle surdité
de l’oreille droite.
Ça prouve qu’on est bien humains,
il n’y a pas de héros,
il n’y a pas de surhomme,
on est tous impactés.
Chaque homme du GIGN
quitte en étant très blessé.
Voilà.
Beaucoup n’aiment pas qu’on le dise ;
c’est vrai qu’il y a une certaine pudeur.
D’ailleurs, quand je suis parti du GIGN,
j’ai écrit un livre.
J’ai eu cette proposition d’écrire.
J’ai eu du mal ; c’est compliqué
de partager tout mon parcours, mon passé,
mais les arguments de mon co-auteur
étaient plutôt bons :
« Est-ce que toi, à l’âge de 16 ans,
si tu avais eu un livre où un opérationnel
aurait partagé son expérience
en expliquant justement
le côté humain de la chose,
est-ce que ça t’aurait aidé ? »
Rappelez-vous ce que j’ai dit :
bien sûr que ça m’aurait aidé.
Ça m’aurait évité cette remise en question
et ça m’aurait permis
d’y croire plus vite.
Donc, je me suis lancé dans l'écriture.
Mais cette écriture n’a pas été
sans conséquence.
Parce que le fait de partager sans filtre,
de dire les choses avec le cœur,
ça nous met à nu.
Se mettre à nu dans notre société,
c’est extrêmement compliqué.
Ça a été compliqué
de par mes anciens collègues,
mes anciens camarades, l’institution.
Je vais généraliser à l’institution.
L’institution va tout mettre en œuvre
pour construire une image du GIGN
qui rassure la population.
Qu’est-ce qu’il y a de plus rassurant
que d’avoir un Robocop à disposition
qui va vous défendre ?
Robocop est inhumain, c’est un robot.
La peur, il ne connaît pas ; la force,
il l’a constamment, il l’a tout le temps.
La faiblesse, il ne connaît pas.
Et là, j’étais en train
de montrer un visage du GIGN,
[celui] d’un homme avec ses qualités,
sa force, sa faiblesse,
sa vulnérabilité parfois.
Ça n’a pas forcément été
très bien pris par l’institution.
Ensuite, il y avait la population,
les gens qui vont regarder le partage
des vidéos, qui vont lire les livres,
qui voient le GIGN comme le super-héros
qui va les défendre,
sur qui on peut compter.
Et là, ils se rendent compte que
la personne sur qui on peut compter,
elle a des faiblesses.
Donc j’ai été pas mal attaqué
par des gens sur les réseaux
qui ont mis ma parole en doute :
« Mais non, c’est un mytho,
ce n’est pas possible.
Ce qu’il dit est complètement faux. »
Et là , j’ai vraiment fini
par avoir le syndrome de l’imposteur,
et par douter de qui j’étais,
de ce que j’avais fait,
de ma légitimité à partager.
« Je suis peut-être allé trop vite.
Peut-être que j’ai trop dévoilé
et on remet en cause ce que je suis. »
J’étais perdu.
J’avais deux solutions :
soit je posais le deuxième genou à terre -
j’en avais posé un -
et je quittais la scène médiatique.
Mais avec l’ambition de devenir acteur,
ça aurait été compliqué.
Ou alors je cherche à comprendre.
Et je cherche la force.
Et là, j’ai été chercher l’essentiel :
« Est-ce que ce que
j’ai raconté est faux ? »
« Est-ce que j’ai cherché la gloire ? »
« Est-ce que mon intention
est mauvaise ? »
Elle n’est pas mauvaise ;
mon intention, c’est le partage :
montrer que ce qui nous impacte
en tant qu’humains impacte tout le monde.
Si j’ai réussi à faire certaines choses,
à atteindre mon objectif,
ça veut dire que vous pouvez atteindre
les vôtres, aussi différents soient-ils.
Est-ce que je cherchais la gloire ?
Certainement pas.
Car la gloire, je l’ai cherchée
à un moment donné.
Comme tout le monde,
j’ai cherché la reconnaissance -
que je n’ai pas toujours eue,
et que bon nombre de militaires n’ont pas.
Ce n’est pas forcément le seul moteur,
mais ça peut en être un à notre vocation,
à notre élan, pour aller travailler,
pour aller mettre notre vie en jeu.
Elle est très importante, mais ce n’est
pas forcément ma motivation première.
Et les remerciements qu’on m’adressait,
est-ce qu’ils étaient volés ?
Non, ils n’étaient pas volés car
ce que j’avais fait, je l’avais bien fait.
Donc j’ai pris ma part des remerciements :
« Merci de me remercier. »
Parce qu’effectivement,
je mérite des remerciements.
« Ah ! Il n’est pas humble ! »
Pensez ce que vous voulez,
je prends les « merci ».
Mais sachez une chose :
tout ce que j’ai pu faire,
je ne l’ai pas fait seul
et j’ai toujours tourné
l’axe de ce projecteur vers les unités.
Et là, c’est encore une occasion
de partager, de dire :
« Vous me voyez,
vous pouvez me dire merci.
Mais ces gens-là sont humains
comme je me suis présenté à vous.
Exactement pareils. »
Et les choses évoluent.
Le fait de se relever comme ça
me donne aussi la force maintenant
de me tourner vers autre chose.
Dans pas longtemps,
il va y avoir un événement
qui est extrêmement important
et qui met tout ça à jour,
tous ces doutes qu’on a pu
me mettre dans ma tête,
c’est la remise de la Légion d’honneur -
j’en suis extrêmement fier.
La personne qui va me remettre cette
Légion d’honneur, c’est Thierry Prungnaud.
Souvenez-vous : celui qui est rentré
le premier dans l’avion à Marignane,
qui a suscité cette vocation en moi,
qui m’a remis le brevet et qui va
bientôt me remettre la Légion d’honneur.
Je me dis qu’il y a
quand même une constante.
Si lui qui m’a inspiré
est encore là aujourd’hui,
c’est que j’ai toute la légitimité
pour être là et faire ce partage.
Lui me dit :
« C’est très bien, tu l’as fait. »
Maintenant, je me tourne vers l’avenir,
Hollywood, les acteurs en France, tout ça.
Mes premières pensées étaient :
« Waouh ! Hollywood, Stallone. »
Je reviens à ma perception d’avant.
Ma perception d’adolescent n’avait pas
changé parce que j’avais mis ça de côté.
Quand je repense acteur, je me dis :
« Stallone, c’est Rocky, c’est Rambo,
mais c’est avant tout
Sylvester Stallone, l’homme.
Donc, si lui, l’homme,
a réussi à être Rocky, à être Rambo,
ça veut dire que,
moi aussi, je peux l’être. »
On a tous tourné - tous les hommes
du GIGN de 1974 jusqu’à aujourd’hui -
on a tous abandonné de porter la tenue,
on a passé le flambeau aux autres,
aux nouveaux qui ont succédé
et qui continuent encore.
Nous, on s’est mis en retrait.
Batman - il y a eu une tenue Batman,
il y a eu un premier Batman.
Le costume n’a pas vraiment changé,
mais l’acteur qui a enfilé la tenue,
il a changé et il a vieilli.
Il y a un relais qui se passe comme ça.
Tout ça pour vous dire
que ce n’est pas le -
Ce n’est pas la cagoule
qui va faire -
Ce n’est pas la cagoule qui va faire
l’homme, qui va faire le GIGN.
Ce qui va faire le GIGN,
ce sont les hommes,
avec leurs qualités, leurs défauts,
leurs faiblesses et leur humanité.
Tout ça pour vous dire
qu’on peut avoir
une vision très idéalisée du héros.
Quand on a un objectif en tête,
qu’on se dit :
« Je veux tendre vers ça,
et ça me paraît impossible »,
faites le chemin inverse.
De l’étoile,
amenez les choses jusqu’à vous.
Vous verrez qu’en fait, ça vous
donnera le chemin pour aller à l’inverse.
Quels que soient vos objectifs,
si vous démystifiez un peu la chose -
il faut toujours garder
cette part de rêve -
je vous assure que tout sera possible.
Voilà.